lá votar com festa mais na saúde
enquanto que estava à espera segundo par
de gêmeos temendo fui eu venho aqui
contar a história da nossa família um
filme e nos tempos de hoje é diferente é
diferente porque seu rápido mais em dois
anos
sábado 2 o site é eu eo meu marido temos
de conseguir 11 ante e e há quatro anos
que usamos e domingos sempre eu sempre
quis casar ter filhos e antes dos 30
anos cria cria 2 fitch já tinha pouco
tempo tenhamos 28 antes e 2003
desconforto gravura fotografia e afinal
não era um eram 2010
ficamos um pouco assustados com medo
apreensivo espera primeira é a primeira
vez que o rapaz portanto temos o menor
mal começo mas ficámos ainda com mais
medo por serem dois pensavam como é que
vamos dar amor algumas crianças como é
que vamos cuidar dos bebés não sabemos
quem vai a uma fralda
como é que eu vou dar uma marca dois
bbbs como é que isso vai acontecer
pronto no dia que fez 30 anos contados a
nossa mística ea nossa família e amigos
e pais e cheguei com minha saúde e
encontramos esse indício porque
realmente uma trindade era uma alegria e
um guincho conseguiu então realizar o
seu e realizar o seu sonho em ter dois
filhos com 30 anos e de 2014 e
descobrindo que realmente o nosso grande
desafio dos pais é um desafio que não
foi fácil porque eram dois bebés noites
e noites sem dormir porque lá no mar
dois bebés o tempo para dormir é muito
pouco mas a prova superada e mais fácil
do que nós podemos achar que nós
pensávamos que a ajuda da nossa família
que foi nosso apoio e temos que
agradecer muito por estar sempre por
perto ajudaram
chan fazer nenhuma coisa de causa avelar
ver se toda hora quando o núcleo dormir
já não agüenta mais cansaço mas hoje um
clube grande nunca chegavam os dois ao
mesmo tempo sejam sempre quando é
criança chorar era uma grande ajuda se
chorava ou outro não chegava
principalmente matilda tinha cólicas e
chorava ao inverno vez ao lado do marido
mas nem o edu me ficar atentos também
cobravam conosco é uma coisa latina
no verão de 2014
o goiás no fim de 2014 no último dia do
ano é faça um teste de gravidez achar
não é impossível clark claro que não
estou mas para tirar as dúvidas fiz fiz
um de negativo e passava os dias fiz
outra positivo é ficarmos receber o que
vamos fazer favor do américa o médico
não deu certezas disse não esperar muito
ser e voltaremos lá passaram uma semana
e descobrimos que estávamos à espera de
gémeos outra vez nós a cabeça eo mesmo a
chorar não ficar completamente sem chão
dos pratos
a vontade era choraram ser e pensar que
estamos assim a que não era possível
como ele dizia que que não conheciam
casos como nós nos pastor em quatro
meses ter quatro filhos é puxada tinha
tido uma cesariana portanto além de tudo
era perigoso ter outras e nem tão perto
foi o méxico com esse segredo entre os
dois e os nossos pais até que tenhamos
coragem contarmos a nossa família nossos
amigos de uma forma mais pra cá tem
muito mais cheia porque exatamente
contente com a situação porque a
maternidade e e ter filhos é uma bênção
estamos com medo e muito apreensivo
porque eu ser tempos difíceis então você
muitas mudanças mas tínhamos que começar
aqui o caixão de católicos e se deus não
estava proporcionar essa missão esse
desafio se eles conversaram na minha
forma e voltar com tudo pronto e
descrevemos 132 em conjunto se chamar
unido team foi que depois criei o blog
as partes foi a partir desse texto que
resolvi partilhar a nossa
entretanto no verão de 2015 então não
cheiram genes e francisca maria do carmo
que vieram então computar a nossa
família numerosa
então em 2 ante o twente conseguiu
concretizar o seu sonho em ter e não
dois filhos meus quatro filhos com 31
anos e tinha quatro filhos
tivemos que dar o máximo de coisas na
nossa vida mudar o chip e casa porque
não estávamos preparados para ter tantos
filhos o carro 45 lugares é impossível
vemos com varias tutu questão financeira
também foi complicada porque não era um
dia para o outro que uma pessoa tem é fã
da área e fazer muitas mudanças
medicamento 45 não dava pois querem
estudos ao médico onde fosse
e pronto o bloco vai vai ajudar a
partilhar diariamente com consumidores e
controlar a gente essa história porque
ao partilhar a nossa história é pré além
de the top retrospectiva da nossa vida e
tentarmos aprender a servir os meus pais
partilharmos com outras pessoas que
estão em situações parecidas assim a
gente às vezes passa a ter um filho mas
só fica com um fica com o começo e
estável principalmente mães de gêmeos
kaká que aparecem por lá todos os dias
sem receber as mensagens de pedir ajuda
e ea mensagem que queremos passar é que
tudo é possível
claro que é difícil é bastante
complicado passamos noites que não dormi
mas nem sequer uma hora porque a gm é
pra ver estes dois já a dormirem na
quinta-feira os outros né e outras bem a
china é complicado mas as coisas
fazem-se somos uma família frisch dentro
de todas as limitações
esperamos que em 2060 e omite estejamos
numa ilha paradisíaca que é a desfrutar
das medidas férias e bursite cães da
brigada